finally this big reveal oh man
exhausting yeah i feel like uh toby
mcguire
no it's crazy you can finally tell
people yeah yeah yeah no it's uh it's
been hard to to keep this one a secret
and uh but a lot of fun you know it's
exciting to to get to be a part of this
world and lucasfilm is always a world i
wanted to kind of you know sneak my way
into so i literally did
i literally snuck my way into this world
yeah how does it feel to be a part of
something that is quite frankly 34 years
in the making
uh
it's unbelievable that yeah i guess i
feel like tom cruise now i feel like tom
toby maguire now i feel like tom cruise
yeah um
uh but no this is uh certainly a project
that uh that i loved growing up
uh i was thrilled i thought it i felt
like it was it was due for a sequel you
know and i wanted to see what happened
to uh
uh to willow and and this this whole
adventure i i was really thrilled to to
get to be a part of it yeah and lastly
is it hard to keep something like this a
secret
uh a little bit i mean i'm not on social
media so i didn't have the pressure of
like you know letting something out in
that particular way
um
uh but yeah you know it was a little
hard it was uh i really wanted to
announce it also because i do love the
character you know so i i really kind of
can't wait for people to see it like
this is
uh
it's it's not like a
a dark character it's a fun character
and and uh you know some stuff happened
kind of organically while we were
filming that uh were pretty hilarious
ooh okay thank you so much sure